Congrats Farnum slices excited to work
with you in support of the student
experience Farnum housing services want
to remind you you can't spell president
without resident best wishes from
University Health Services dear
president Jehan e'en on behalf of
community health and well-being we want
to wish you the best of luck and
congratulations and remind you to take
deep breaths as you model the way for
our campus community
my name is Shree Gupta I'm a sophomore
here at Carnegie Mellon University
studying biomedical and chemical
engineering I wanted to say
congratulations to Farnum on being
inaugurated as the 10th president of
Carnegie Mellon University
congratulations and good luck what the
servers are on fire sorry on behalf of
student affairs I'd sorry IT support
what you've lost all the student data
by the way congratulations president
jihadi at the career professional
development center we are in the
business of getting people jobs and
we're so excited about your new job hi
I'm Matt I'm a sophomore studying
Computer Engineering and Applied Science
here at CMU and congratulations
president farming them on becoming the
10th president of CMU hello president
rouhani in on behalf of conference and
event services and free college we wish
you the best and we look forward to what
your presidency will bring to our campus
community good luck and best wishes
Congrats Farnum when becoming the tenth
president of Carnegie Mellon University
we're really excited to have you
congratulations congratulations dad for
becoming the 10th president of the
university and thanks for being my dad
we think your appointment is a big deal
congratulations orientation is all about
helping students in transition
congratulation there's only one way to
express our emotions the thorn emoji
from all of us in marketing and
communications
congratulations dr. John audience throws
our yard slam dunk
congratulations farmer we could be
prouder than you're turning the course
for Carnegie Mellon
you
hi president Jehan Yin it's been my good
fortune to be a member of the Carnegie
Mellon family for 20 years and I'm
really excited to see what your
leadership over into this university and
as the newest member accelerating like
two-month anniversary in the office of
the Dean of Students I can already feel
the energy of your presidency alright
everybody it's time for our selfie on
behalf of the staff of the Carnegie
Mellon portugal's program I would like
to congratulate to Farnum on your
inauguration we wish you the best wishes
for the best to come and we hope the
Kinect's partnership to a successful
future congratulations president - hey
Nia
[Music]
their forum on behalf of the hundred and
twenty nine students twenty faculty
members 15 staff members and nearly
hundred and fifty alumni of CMU Africa
I'm delighted to offer congratulations
on behalf of the entire student body at
Carnegie Mellon University Africa would
like to congratulate you president onion
on your inauguration dear Farnum the
faculty staff and students of Carnegie
Mellon University in Australia to
congratulate you in your investiture as
the new president of the University we
look forward to your dynamic leadership
and we look forward to contributing to
making this a great campus of CMU in the
Asia Pacific congratulations on behalf
of 151 students at Carnegie Mellon
University Australia we like to
congratulate President John Young for
your appointment as Japan president of
Carnegie Mellon University we are really
excited for the upcoming presidency
willing to make meaningful initiative
for the asia-pacific from poverty to
urbanization from education to health a
lot of opportunities to combine public
policy and information management to
solve it properly but don't take our
word for it take theirs on behalf of the
entire College of Engineering I'd like
to congratulate you for Ihnen on
becoming the 10th president of Carnegie
Mellon University we truly look forward
to your continued leadership of this
institution I for one am very excited to
be working with you
president hon Ian Congrats on being
appointed it's great to have you as our
10th birthday congratulations president
Jahan Ian we already said to see what
you are going to bring into the CMU
community and going see I know that dr.
Johan Ian actually has a daughter here
and I think that really speaks to his
investment of time and energy into
leading this great University because I
feel like he'll actually treat students
like his children and I think that's
really fitting as the tendon line of
such great presidents of this university
so congrats dr. Johan Ian
congratulations president Jahan you for
this new appointment we are really
excited to see the new changes you'll
bring to our campus and good luck on all
your work here at CMU
congratulations Farnham on your
appointment congratulations Fordham I'm
being inaugurated as the 10th president
of Carnegie Mellon University a couple
of years ago president rouhani and came
to a celebration of the Putnam math
competition because CMU won that
competition that year and he came to
tell us how proud he was even at night
taking some time out of his day it was
really exciting for a prominent CMU
figure to come and show his
congratulations of our program and our
academic strength and I'm really
grateful for all that he's done for our
academic program so far and I'm really
excited for what he'll do as president
of this University
congratulations Farnham we're very
grateful for all that you've done for
civil and environmental engineering for
the College of Engineering and our
entire campus community already we're
delighted that you're our leader we look
forward to working with you
years ahead congratulations Farnum I
look forward to an exciting future for
Carnegie Mellon under your leadership
congratulations Farnum I've had the
pleasure to work with you and your many
roles at CMU and I'm confident that CMU
will realize its full potential under
your leadership Farnham congratulations
on being selected as the 10th president
of Carnegie Mellon University I'm
excited to watch the university flourish
under your continued leadership I often
have seen you walking around campus
talking to staff and faculty and
students congratulating them and telling
them how proud you are of their
accomplishments well today's our day to
tell you how proud we are of your
accomplishments and how extremely happy
we are that you are our tenth president
of Carnegie Mellon University okay John
I know you did a video to congratulate
Farnum so did I what else could we do to
congratulate foriegn him on his
inauguration you know there is that most
important competition all of the
University how could I forgotten